you talked about like you know your
relationship with Empire shoutout to
Ghazi what is it about working with
Ghazi that like you you don't think cuz
a lot of you know I feel like Empire is
this island in the middle of the music
industry that some people know about but
other people are like what is going on
over there like what is it about working
with what Empire and gauzy that to you
is like special and sets sets that
company apart cuz I know God sees when
the smartest guys I know so coming out
the trenches I felt like when I talked
to energy I mean
record labels my main request was uh you
know just freedom to do whatever I want
as far as creatively and that's what
they offered they told me I'm entitled
to do whatever I want they ain't try to
change my music then II try to dilute it
then come with no like look you should
do this and you know they don't even
suggest things that that's out of my
lane you know and they let me be me they
let me do me I'm entitled to drop at
will the fact that everything is so
transparent you know all the deals is
transparent it's like um
you know I said 12th grader can
understand the whole if they sit down
and talk with you and you're a twelfth
grader they could they could bus it down
somebody who's new to this business
never done any type of work in this
business they can their make it
transparent for you to understand and
then they're follow through with that
it's not like you know you know how fine
print mm-hmm it's everything is clear
and I was able to comprehend and
understand it and see that this is the
situation best is best for me it
benefits me of course I wanted to take
the long way I didn't want to jump on
the elevator I wanted to run the stairs
so on you know and they and they
assisted me with their you know they got
behind me man and like I said they word
is is it's platinum anything they say
they gonna do they follow through when
they come with these deals or you know
however it's I feel like I feel like
they family I feel like if I go broke
today I can call guys and say
better better Sammy firm he wanted them
amberleigh's me right where you gonna
work it over you film that feel like I
could call me name team I need a honey
cake
like today dough right and he afford
that over and and that's I just it's
crazy the relationship that I got with
him so you know anytime I can I can
[Music]
persuade somebody in it not even
persuade me anytime I could recommend
yeah I'm seeing me or refer somebody the
Empire men I I for surely go about it
you